helping inmates get back on their feet
before they're released from jail our
hector mejia tells us how a resource
fair the clark county detention center
is helping inmates get back into the
community
meet kelani robinette she says drug
abuse put her behind bars but she's
ready to move on when she gets released
on november 18th very challenging
just
the drugs and stuff like that like
it's just it's getting old you know so
it's like it's time to just change your
life she's one of approximately 80
inmates checking out a resource fair
inside the clark county detention center
in downtown i have all these resources
honestly like i've never been offered
this before so this is new they're
learning about health services housing
job placement things corrections officer
todd laird says are necessary in order
for inmates to get their life back on
track
so if we can get someone out of custody
get back on the right track give them
the help that they need
it makes it better for our whole society
this is the fourth resource fair this
year it all started back in 2019 it
provides an opportunity for these
inmates to see the human side of
corrections officers police officers
hector mejia reporting live local now